hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys sure
you are in certain ways red pubes that's
the joke joke hey baby
there's a big announcement about
spider-man joining Marvel Cinematic
Universe it's so exciting
in case you guys don't know what it is
apparently movieclipstrailers has
released a video putting it together so
we thought why not watch this first to
get you guys updated and then we'll talk
about it
donar people have still continued
watching this video
director fury I think it's time I think
you're the youngest become part of a
bigger universe just don't know
the news is exactly what we said it
would be that was a great video really
informative and I found out through
actually one of my fans on Twitter
myself Al's
and it is true and yeah it isn't
completely confirmed that Marvel has
made a deal with sony Sony still has the
rights to spider-man sadly but at least
they are going to make an agreement I'm
right I read Sony is still like they're
pretty much gonna get in like sixty
percent of the profits though which is
they're gonna finance the film we're
gonna have complete creative control at
the end of the day so they have the
final go ahead on anything they do with
spider-man so literally all the yeah
will allow Marvel to put them in the
film but we still get to control them
basically yeah but whatever percentage
marble is getting is gonna be a pretty
fat check I don't really care about the
thing sitting in a lot of hose no I'm
sure they're gonna give them as much
control as possible I'm sure in the end
they're gonna like I can just take it
away from Sony no everyone already wants
Marvel to have full you know reign over
spider-man and so I don't think they
have a choice
I am personally excited is what they
said they're gonna introduce him through
Captain America Civil War after that
then they would have a Spider Man movie
in like 2017 I believe which is 2018
well I heard 2017 that was for the
amazing spider-man 3 will be released on
July 28th 2017 ok Collider
regardless it's a long freaking time
yeah yeah I know it's a long time to
wait in our last video we talked a lot
about like which actors we think would
be good for it and from my understanding
it's still the same like rumored actors
Logan Lerman
really put in my front and center for
this one can I please just be MJ please
I cannot if she's an even if she's not I
could be an extra I don't care but what
about a prostitute - spider-man ends up
losing his virginity - I'm cool with
that as long as I get it better than
seeing those in their videos so totally
my thing what do you think about Andrew
Garfield not being I think it sucks but
if they do a completely different
interpretation because the reason why
was gonna be a little bit more difficult
to accept Andrew Garfield was because
and then our original reboot it was like
this looks a little bit similar to what
Sam Raimi already did this one sounds
like it could be very different I hear
it's not gonna be in origin tales I
think that they could do something
that's really unique with it that will
really fit into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is like overall theme they have
going on all the Marvel movies are
similar their own ways that way the
Avengers make sense in the end I think
this could be great as long as they can
get spider-man in the Avengers that's
just gonna be awesome
I wish Joss Whedon was doing Avengers 3
only because they're gonna put
spider-man ok my take on this whole
thing to be quite honest he did start
looking really old though like in the
second movie there was a lot more makeup
on him and I didn't really fully believe
that he was getting out of high school
and it was really weird and the fact
that he did kind of crap talk Sony it
kind of gave me the impression that he
didn't even care anymore if you really
cared about being spider-man then you
wouldn't have said something like that
unless I mean I wasn't there when he
said the thing he said about Sony but I
mean he could have just been really sad
that they messed up spider-man
regardless I think he already knew that
even if they were to continue he
wouldn't have enjoyed making the movie
because it wouldn't have been what he
thought was right for the characters
when they do reboot this new spider-man
I don't think they should focus on the
romantic thing they just focused on
maybe more relationships with the
villains and why they're villains
instead of it just being like I hate
man let's kill him I think that would
make him more interesting and I wouldn't
want to watch it more but you know if
they put MJ in it I would love I hear
they're still gonna be doing sinister
six which is still pretty cool to me I
never be coming out probably 2018 or
something I feel like if Marvel has most
of the creative control at least okay
we're just gonna get the green light on
whatever you guys they know Marvel those
are they're doing better otherwise it
weren't how many clothes do you know I
think spider-man might get it the best
reaping yet in some fashion more than
just cool websley and I think we might
get a real story then like everyone's
gonna be on board for and everyone
already knows his backstory already so I
hope they can do something a little
different rather than just repeating
what we've seen like a thousand times we
should explore spider-man's like sexual
life you know and we could really find
out if what comes out of his peepee is
really a web yeah
it could be a white semen where Annika
like so because the semen web another
thing people are trying to petition that
Tobey is going to come back as the new
spider-man what would you think about
that I would have to say Tobey Maguire
is a little too wrinkly now for that
role yeah I don't think at the end of
the day they can make a horrible
decision with casting Peter Parker I
think they're gonna be fine
there's so many hot actors that I would
not mind watching again spider-man's
Ryan Gosling 32 year old actor Ryan
Gosling plays high school sweetheart you
could check out our video when the
rumors are just out since most of those
rumors are true now where we you know
talk about more of this [ __ ]
it was foreshadowing we totally told -
we got a lot of it right because we
reported on what the news was telling us
that's why we're smart but yeah if you
guys are new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out Salomon or Sally's channel
there's a lot of budge [ __ ] on there
check it out right away
Oh videos gonna die right now
Oh